[Musik]
grundsätzlich beworben Fehlen
aufklärungsart der Harry Potter und es
war keines frei und dann letztendlich
war dann die Frage ja jähriges
truppenschule aber nicht in der Funktion
des Aufklärers sondern in der Funktion
als
Referent in der grundlagenabteilung in
Eisenstadt
auf meine Frage hin an den Leiter der
grundlagenabteilung was gibt es sonst
noch für eine Funktion oder zu einer
heeresgruppenschule
es war kurz vor Weihnachten
2007 ja der Leiter Institut Aufklärung
ist auch noch frei in denen
und die hat dann auch okay das ist
eigentlich eine ganz tolle Sache wenn
ich jetzt das Ziel habe in weiterer
Folge wieder zu einem aufklärungszugehen
dann nutze ich die Gelegenheit und
beschäftige mich die nächsten Jahre bis
dorthin eben mit Aufklärung und das habe
ich dann vier Jahre gemacht dann
Zwölfaxing begonnen mit einem
Unteroffizier und habe also dort das
Institut aufgegangen aufgebaut
insofern auch interessant weil die
ersten Lehrgänge sind schon wenige
Monate aufgetaucht und das
ausbildungsunterstützungspersonal oder
mit anderen für sie machen waren Leute
aus Ferien also vom ab7 und so aber
meine erste Berührung auch mit den
Ferien Aufklärern das waren also meine
vier Jahre hier in Zwölfaxing und dann
wurde eben 2011 der Arbeitsplatz
ausgeschrieben und dann war für mich
jetzt ist soweit Artillerie ist bist ja
schon gewesen jetzt die Aufklärung
jetzt als nächster Schritt das
aufklärungs und so war ich dann auch
einer von die vier bewerberser zwei von
den vier Bewerbern ist damals gegeben
weil er tatsächlich beim Hering beim
damaligen Minister barabosch
und
er hat mich dann auf einem riesengroßen
Tisch statt in unserem Büro empfangen
und befragt sie haben sich jetzt um
diese Funktion des Artillerie Aufklärung
oder wie wie heißt das ja um das
aufklärungscenter 7 beworben
von denen es ja drei gibt im Bundesheer
aber nur eines funktioniert das hatte
natürlich schon einmal jetzt dann als
Einstieg
sehr überrascht und sagt das müssen wir
das erklären also genau es gibt eines
das ist das ab4 in allen steigt da habe
ich auch wesentlich mitgearbeitet im
Vorfeld Rahmen der vierten
Panzergrenadierbrigade das wirklich gut
funktioniert da gibt es eine SIM
Mistelbach das eben als reines
aufklärungsbataillon jetzt zu einem AAB
umzugsstrukturieren ist wirklich nicht
vergleichbar sehr sehr schwierig das zu
machen
und das ab7 wo ich nicht verstehe warum
das noch nicht funktioniert weil die
Artillerie ist ja vorhanden die
Aufklärer sitzt in Fehring einmal
braucht diese Dinge eigentlich nur
verschmelzen und den entsprechend auch
die Führungsfähigkeit hier dieses dieser
dieses hybridenverbands-
und nachdem wir die Aufklärer jung dafür
sichere Offiziere schon kannte von den
von den dienstverteilungen an der
Touristen sowieso schon kannte von
früher man braucht man mit diesen Leuten
geht das und es gibt also keine Grund es
ist nicht funktionieren kann und somit
habe ich auch mehr oder weniger
im dargestellt wie ich das ganze machen
werde ja
und das Ziel war mal wirklich
die fähigkeitsentwicklung dieses
aufklärungsverbandes voranzutreiben und
zwar weniger so auf eine Ebene sondern
eher im bataillonskommando Führung
dieser zwei
Teilfähigkeiten und das ist uns glaube
ich ganz gut gelungen weil eineinhalb
Jahre alt später im Rahmen einer
multinationalen Übung wo eigentlich
ursprünglich das Bataillon so wie eben
Jahre davor oder meiner Vorgänger das
klassische rollplayer-bataillon war also
das
feinddarstellerbataillon
jeder braucht dann irgendwo einen
feindarsteller
wo also von vorne a bis eben macht das
veränderbar das haben Sie schon mal gut
gemacht und so weiter nur gewusst damit
gewinnst du keine Medaille du bist du
bist zwar ja dann bedankt sich jeder
dass du das gut gemacht hast wenn du
quasi das wir auf einer Bühne die die
bühnebient hin und her schiebst aber
letztendlich
der Schauspieler bekommt dann
letztendlich den Applaus und nicht der
Bühnen Schieber der es im Hintergrund
dann auch notwendig ist aber
dann letztendlich nicht vor dem Vorhang
gebeten wird und das wollte ich nicht
ich wollte also dass die Arbeit auch der
Leute anerkannt wird und gezeigt wird
und es war dann natürlich gibt es zu
Zufälle und glückliche Fügungen und so
weiter es ist uns tatsächlich gelungen
aus dieser dieser rollplayer-funktion
herauszukommen und letztendlich dann als
AAP dort eingesetzt zu sein
überlegungsteam sind in der ersten Woche
gleich aufgetaucht und aber nicht nur
bei Denise aufklärungscompanie das wenn
man schon da sind evaluieren wir alles
also auch das bataillonskommando die
panzerwitz-batterie und so weiter und
sehr vorsagen mal recht dann haben wir
schwarz auf weiß wo wir ungefähr stehen
bei unserer fähigkeitenentwicklung und
war wo wir noch nachsteuern müssen oder
sollen
herausgekommen bei dieser Evaluierung
dass wir eigentlich wirklich
als eine der besten die besten aber
wirklich ja als einer der besten
abgeschnitten haben in allen
Teilfähigkeiten nicht nur in euch das
Spiel Aufklärung ich den Bereich der
Bereitstellung Informationen nicht den
Bereich der
Einsatzes der Artillerie der schweren
Waffen sondern auch im Hinblick auf die
Durchhaltefähigkeit wenn man jetzt
einmal dann 10 Tage übten den Verband
den gibt's ja eh nicht der so so zehn
Tage in einem Stück übt brauchst du
entsprechendes reservekonzept und das
war dann so dass wir wirklich
kontinuierlich mehr oder weniger Übung
hätte noch eine Woche länger dauern
können
kontinuierlich unsere Leistung quasi
gebracht das heißt ja dann durchgehend
auf Grün was also die Leistungsfähigkeit
und die und die Durchhaltefähigkeit
Betroffenen und wir sagen nie einen
gelben bzw in einer Rauschen Bereich
gerutscht ja und der zweite Teil an
meiner Tätigkeit in oder meiner Arbeit
in Feldbach war eben die Beschäftigung
der Infrastruktur
erstens einmal wurde ja Fehring dann in
meiner Zeit auch aufgelöst und die
Aufklärung mussten nach Feldbach
übersiedeln
war so haben wir auch als Chance gesehen
weil wir gewusst haben beide Standorte
general sanieren ist kaum möglich
aufgrund der Budget der Situation wenn
dann muss man sich auf einen Standort
konzentrieren und das haben wir auch den
entsprechend ausgenutzt und
auch dann eingefordert erstens einmal
die Generalsanierung der bestehenden
Gebäude in Feldbach und meine
Nachfolgern ist ja das dann ein ganz gut
gelungen auch durch diesen ersatzprofil
fairing letztendlich
zu errichten und der Stein Standort
zumindest in der Südsteiermark erhalten
bleibt ja weil eben
die ist ein guter Boden ist gutes
Personal und
immer einen guten Job gemacht hat
die Auftragslage für Aufklärung war gut
die aufgelauftragslage für für alle
anderen Aufgaben die heute im Bataillon
zu machen war auch gut das Budget war
eher dürftig und die Auftragslage für
Artilleristen war Null gegen Null gehend
und auch da damalige Brigade kannst du
ich brauche jetzt
2012 keine artillerieausbildung
konzentriert sich auf die Aufklärung und
da ist eben diese Idee geboren okay wie
übernehmen trotzdem dieses jetzt doch
dieses System kann man den erstens damit
kann ich die Artilleristen
zukunftsorientiert beschäftigen und
es kommt Geld in die Kasse ja schon
Überstunden Verlegungen Geld für
Munition und so weiter und so fort auch
Geld für an für Begleitmaßnahmen indem
wir uns braucht und das war eigentlich
dann ein Goldgräber also wir haben das
Projekt übernommen
im Prinzip meine Leute haben es dann im
Prinzip gemacht und
das war sozusagen die Trägerrakete für
uns sowohl also für die Entwicklung des
ABS ja ich kann kein a b entwickeln wenn
die Artillerie vernachlässigt ich muss
beides zusammenführen den weiteren Folge
auch also sprich die Rechtfertigung man
braucht damit militärischen Nutzen immer
vorweisen kann und dann auch ein
weiterer Folge die die Einforderung der
der Budgetmittel für die Infrastruktur
also das war von Anfang bis zum Schluss
hin eigentlich die Trägerrakete die uns
genutzt hat um unsere Anliegen Freiheit
zu bringen ja das war maubel Zufall
aber letztendlich
auch wieder der Verdienst der Leute die
also das dann angenommen haben und die
ganzen Schwierigkeiten gelöst haben